Awesome.
Do you feel like you could just say that instead of appreciate that this is to
intellectuals discussing something that's very complex and that it is,
it was about immigration and about Islam and those are two things that people
don't want to hear.
You know,
they just like go,
those two things are off limits.
Unless you're a pro Islam or pro immigration,
you better shut the fuck up,
but we're going to demonetize you.
And that,
that kind of censorship is fascinating to me because it's,
it's not effective.
It's a,
it just,
it just makes people go,
hey,
and you know,
and then it makes the people on the youtube side get defensive and it makes them
double down and you know,
and,
and you're seeing,
you see that now?
I mean,
you see it with many people.
It's,
it's a weird time for ideas.
Yeah.
How do you feel about being part of the Idw,
the international dark web?
Uh,
I'm,
I'm the least mentioned,
happily the least mentioned person in that group.
I'm very happy about that.
I don't like being in any groups.
It,
Groucho Marx once say,
uh,
I don't want to be a part of any club that would have me.
It's just,
look,
I'm very happy to be able to have a platform where I can have people like you on
or any of those people,
whether it's Bret Weinstein or Eric Weinstein Stein,
sorry guys,
Bret Weinstein era after Harvey.
Everybody got real uncomfortable.
He's really sweet.
He's great.
And his wife Heather is amazing as well.
He'll be on actually the next season of wrong speak.
Oh cool.
Heather hiring his wife is amazing too and they were on together.
Um,
and Sam Harris is a good friend and I love that guy.
He's fast.
Any person and as,
as Jordan and a look,
I don't agree with a lot of what Ben Shapiro says,
but he's a super nice guy and I really like him,
you know?
And that's,
that's,
you saw that thing that happened with that actor mark was the same mark Duplass
is that his name?
Got In trouble for tweeting that uh,
you know,
very nice and reasonable person.
Yeah.
It's a fun time then is really nice too.
He's a really nice guy.
You know,
I like him a lot.
This a internet,
whatever it is,
the dark web thing,
that's all Eric,
Eric Weinstein's idea was to name this and label.
He loves all that Shit.
He loves all that cloak and dagger stuff.
He gets a kick out of it,
but he makes some very good points and he's a brilliant,
brilliant guy.
And um,
this idea that we're all joined together,
I mean we all went out,
we had a big dinner together,
like a bunch of dorks and we all got together and we're like this little club
and that's kind of fun and we're going to do it again.
And we're,
we're bringing more people into,
we're bringing more people into the dark web.
If some people are that they're not a part of the dark web.
And I'll tell you some names afterwards,
but some people like contacted Barry Weiss and were upset that they weren't
included in the dark web.
I love Karen.
I loved Barry's column.
It was interesting.
Yeah.
It's the whole,
but the label of it all.
I mean,
it's,
what's interesting is it,
it starts this conversation,
right?
So why is it even necessary?
You have this dark web and what's the function of this dark web and what is
this?
What is the dark web doing?
Really like what,
what is,
you know,
and there was an article today where someone was calling it problematic and
saying that it's mostly right leaning people,
which is absolutely not true.
Sam Harris very left a Bret Weinstein,
fiercely progressive.
Eric very left.
Um,
I'm way more left than I am,
right?
I the very few right wing ideas that I hold on to their very small,
it's very,
the vast majority of my positions on things side with,
uh,
with people on the left vast majority.
Um,
Ben Shapiro was very right,
but he's reasonable,
you know,
and he's also a young guy,
conservative religious.
It's,
but he's also extremely intelligent and reasonable talk to him.
And he has himself,
um,
disavowed some of the things that he said.
And he's,
he's himself criticized his own words.
He wrote a whole call.
Here's a list of all the stupid things I've ever said online.
You know,
and because he's,
he's,
you know,
he's a very aware guy,
very self aware.
I think.
Um,
I think it's important to have discussions and I think it's important that when
people feel like those discussions are being suppressed,
that they talk about that.
And I think that's what this whole thing is.
And I think you're a part of that as well.
I was in the column,
yeah,
we could use you in the dark web,
a woman of color to it.
You guys aren't all racist white people.
God Damn it.
I took a 23 and me and I'm hoping I've got some black gray and I'm hoping for
you to give me some,
give me more than 5%.
What is it that you have to have?
I think you only have to have like one 16th native American to catch a check in
some places.